ten years ago California voters approved
three billion dollars to create a state
stem-cell agency the California
Institute for regenerative medicine
what is the agency accomplished in would
Californians vote to give it five
billion more dollars in 2016 we asked
baseball fans who were on their way to a
game near the agency's headquarters we
both voted for it we work for you want
it to happen well I feel like California
is doing a good thing when we should
keep funding that I'm not vehemently
opposed to it but I'm kind of opposed to
it I just I don't know I don't know if
we were meant to go in this direction I
voted no I'm a retired physics teacher
and I think that's one of the best
investments we've ever made and I hope
they invest 15 billion I vote for it in
a second I think that's way too much
money but honestly I'm not well-educated
on the stem cells so it might be worth
it
who knows I don't know I have no idea I
mean schools need more money than when
the California Institute for
regenerative medicine was first approved
in 2004 there was very little federal
support for stem-cell research
California's unusual state funding
strategy was a big boost for the
discipline people forget in the early
2000s were very few cell lines we can
work with there were very few scientists
who were trained in the field to work on
it and there was actually very little
research funding I know there have been
a cycle problems but I think they're
unreasonable I think that it's
definitely something that if it saves
lives and it's worth using we don't have
a cure yet that's been derived from
embryonic stem cells and I think we're a
number of years away from having a cure
what we have though is a pipeline of new
drugs be they cells or chemicals that
have been derived from this research
which are being tested in humans now and
I'm pretty optimistic that over the next
few years we will be seeing real drugs
that will change the lives of people in
2016 voters will be asked to approve
more money for the Asian
you know the NIH still doesn't fund
stem-cell research at the level that it
needs to be funded so having these other
sources of funding have been still to
this day essential to move the field
forward so will Californians vote for
five billion more dollars in funding
William oh yeah that sounds a lot better
I think they deserve a good amount of
money I would evoke yes everybody is
asking for money every and there's just
so much of it I don't know how I vote on
that I really don't I love physics don't
get me wrong
baseball physics yum yum but stem cells
save lives how can you top that
you